going back to what ratos said
framelayout
linear layout and relative layout are
three of the most common layouts you'll
use in building out your UI these all
descend from the view group class
designed to contain and give order to
child views they each have their
strengths and you should always try to
use the simplest layout that will get
the job done frame loud is great for
simple layouts when you only have one
child of you like a ListView that fills
the entire content area linear layout is
perfect for stacking views vertically or
horizontally one after another it is
also the only way to break up the
display proportionately relative layout
is powerful but a bit more complicated
compared to the others throw a bunch of
views inside a relative layout and then
you can configure each views position
relative to the parent the relative
layout or to sibling views tons of
possibilities we'll explore these
layouts in greater detail when we build
more complex screens for now let's get
back to building our forecast list